Millie Bobby Brown announces her
engagement to boyfriend Jake Bon Jovi
it's such an exciting Moment The
Stranger Things star shared this sweet
black and white snap to Instagram on
Tuesday that's the 19 year old smiling
ear to ear rocking a large diamond ring
on that finger as her man hugs her from
behind
ETS reached out to Millie's rep for
confirmation Millie captioned the pic
with a lyric from Taylor Swift's song
Lover
alive
love her I've loved you three Summers
now honey I want them all I'm really
grateful the comment section was flooded
with well wishes from friends and celebs
like Lonnie Love and Ashley Tisdale
Jake's Uncle Matthew also chimed in with
his congrats Jake who's the 20 year old
son of rock icon John Bon Jovi also
posted pics from the same shoot at the
beach writing simply forever so I would
love nothing more but back to that
diamond diamonds up in here one ring
expert says Millie sparkler is about
three and a half carats and may have
cost anywhere from fifty thousand to one
hundred thousand dollars Millie
previously revealed she met her boo on
Instagram the two sparked dating Rumors
in 2021 and made their red carpet debut
at the bafta awards in March 2022.
and when ET chatted with Millie last
year she gushed over her real-life
leading man you have made it a family
I know he's pretty unbelievable of
course Millie has lots to celebrate
these days last year she starred in
Enola homes too
Sherlock why are you here is it my case
of your own
seems our cases are connected the game
has had its feet again
a part of the film that the audience
feels like they can connect with Enola
because we're breaking the fourth wall
now she's gearing up for the fifth and
final season of stranger things
I don't have my powers
I'm gonna say this other than just to
say it
without you
we can't win this war
have you wrapped your mind around the
final season of stranger things I have
I'm coming to times with it slowly so
I'm ready I'm ready
but for now we hope Millie's loving
engaged life
foreign
[Music]